Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm going to show
you how to track toddlers
[Music]
well guys we have got a serious toddler
and infestation at this house it's been
getting worse and worse over the last
five years and finally it has just
gotten out of control
so in this video what I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you how to one
identify toddler issues and tell whether
or not you have a toddler problem in
your home how to prevent toddlers from
investing your home and also show you
how to humanely trap and relocate
toddlers so let me show you what I'm
talking about so look at this room this
is an awesome game room slash mancave
and it is absolutely overrun with toys
this is a classic sign that you've got a
toddler infestation look at this we've
got all this stuff right here just we
got blankets and toys and no toddlers
think about toddlers is if you see one
there means there's like a hundred more
hiding behind the fridge so definitely
massive toddler infestation another sure
sign that you've got a toddler problem
is finding toddler scat around the house
yeah this one's fresh well some people
think toddlers are cute they are in fact
very destructive it can often be seen
leaving their marks around the house if
a toddler and physician gets really bad
they'll get in between the walls and up
in the crawl spaces and then it's really
hard getting them out so definitely if
you start seeing holes in the walls it's
time to do something about your toddler
problems children are also known to be
common carriers of many infectious
diseases such as flu elephantitis
cholera dengue fever rabies Lou Gehrig's
disease hunt a virus plague also known
as Black Death and menopause chronic
exposure to children is also known to
cause fatigue weight gain headaches lack
of desire and in some cases Tourette
syndrome don't let their looks fool you
folks these little things can be very
dangerous so if you have a toddler
infestation make sure you take care of
it quickly obviously preventing a
toddler infestation is the best way to
avoid these troubles and to do that you
should follow these three simple steps
number one avoid eye contact with
women number two make sure you don't
wash or use deodorant and finally under
no circumstances should you listen to
anything performed by Al Green
none of his albums at all however if you
find yourself in a situation where you
already have a toddler infestation I'm
gonna show you how to humanely catch and
relocate those children so what I have
here is a mock-up of our toddler trap
and for those of you who follow my other
youtube channel the catfish and carp
youtube channel you may recognize this
as the squirrel trap I built for my
squirrel trapping video the way it works
is pretty simple it's basically a box
with a sliding door and a trigger in the
back when the trigger gets sprung down
goes the door and your toddler is
trapped
[Music]
yeah pretty cool night huh I made this
from a farriers rasp you want to see
that video check out the link in the
description below so let me show you my
favorite toddler bait here we go guys
doughnuts assorted dozen that'll
definitely catch some toddlers I know my
local ones like chocolate and raspberry
filled so that should work really well
to set the trap up what you do is you
take this stick with the notch you put
it through the hole and just catch it
just barely on the edge of the wood and
then it's perfectly balanced okay take
one of the doughnuts we're gonna put it
back behind the trigger
all right now the traps baited and we're
ready to catch yourself some toddlers
Oh it worked we caught ourselves the big
one
oh look at that alright guys well we
caught one and he's a big one
Oh be careful now these things can
really bite so don't put your fingers
inside the cage or they will take them
off
isn't that right now here comes the
tricky part we've got to transport them
so I got myself this burlap sack and
we're gonna try to get him inside
oh okay there we go
well we got them subdued and in the sack
how's that donut once you have the kids
secured in the bag you want to sedate
them with some basic chloroform now I
know everybody has their own secret
formula that they like to use but basic
good old-fashioned chloroform is really
hard to beat works every time
alright so we got one in the bag but
that does not solve our problem you got
to get all the toddlers out of the house
or you're just gonna have the same
issues all right so let's rebate the
crap and see if we can catch another one
Oh what do we got in there oh my
goodness all right let's see if we can
get this one in the gunnysack we're
gonna tie the boots up with the good
old-fashioned constrictor knot all right
now I'm gonna chloroform them know how
it works every time with trapping
children you tend to get the big ones
first
so I want to reset the trap and trying
to target the smaller ones and for that
I'm going to use a different type of
bait this formula works really well for
little guys all right okay we got
another one let's check him out let's
see oh look we got a little one these
guys are easy to deal with let's get
them in the gunnysack oh yeah yeah
that's a nice one let's go ahead and put
them in this bag here got them in the
sack
just spray with the chloroform and then
you're good to go all right that's three
of them so we've got three kids in the
bag we're gonna put them on top of the
car and I'm gonna drive them out to a
spot that I've got planned to relocate
that I'm gonna show you how to safely
relocate children all right let's get
them on top man I am so glad I invested
in these roof racks I use these things
all the time all right
[Music]
but my bad
oh they're starting to wake up
starting to wake up chloroform's wearing
off oh oh there you go are you doing the
guy yeah go go play so black okay there
you go those guys make us go play go boy
you know what your kind of acuity
I just might keep you well guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click Subscribe and please leave a
comment and tell me all of your horror
stories of raising kids if you've got a
great story there's something you did
when you're a kid or when you're raising
kids finger-painting with poo letting a
squirrel loose in the house whatever it
was leave it in the comment and let us
share in your pain but thanks for
watching and don't forget to check out
our Nate and Tom video playlist and our
fun project playlist I'll put a link in
the description thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boy's YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video Nathan who you playing with